[Musique]
ici le terrain il commence donc au tous
les P là en haut là où il y a les
parcelles de chou et chouffeur çaed
descend tout en bordure de la forêt et
ça va encore au 300 m plus bas en
dessous de de de ces
[Musique]
parcelles 3 hectares d'exploitation
agricole qui sont une véritable richesse
pour l'environnement Pascal dijou est un
agriculteur soucieux de préserver les
ressources naturelles et la biodiversité
de son île depuis plus de 5 ans il
pratique une agriculture biologique sur
ses parcelles bah pour moi un
agriculteur bio c'est c'est quelqu'un
qui produit qui est agriculteur donc qui
doit qui
produit de du des fruits des légumes des
fleurs tout ça mais aussi qui qui a la
conscience aussi également c'est un
paysagiste un peu aussi également
c'estàd qu'il va pas regarder simplement
donc ce qu'il va planter mais il va
entretenir aussi un écosystème c'est
veut dire un environnement il va en
prendre soin parce que c'est son outil
de travail également c'est un acte un
peu militant ça ve dire que voilà on
soutient ce type d'agriculture parce que
on sait que cefin que c'est
l'agriculture de demain quoi c'est
l'agriculture durable c'est
l'agriculture qui fera que il y aura
moins de pollution un peu partout comme
par rapport aux EAU et les dégâts que ça
peut causer l'agriculture
conventionnelle sur son terrain Pascalou
fait du maréchage en plein champ il
respecte le cycle des saisons et ses
légumes poussent ici sans aucun produit
[Musique]
chimique on peut tout faire en bio à
condition donc de bien maîtriser donc
ces cultures et pour çael en bio on a on
doit toujours donc pratique planifier
bien en avance anticiper ses cultures
anticiper culture c'est comme je vais
vous dire bien gérer les rotations B
disons qu'en bio ce qu'on va faire nous
c'est travailler on va travailler le sol
on va travailler plus sur l'aspect du
sol amander le sol qui lui va restituer
tous les éléments nécessaires au bon
développement de la plante donc on va
travailler essentiellement sur la la vie
du sol le compostage et au contraire
donc de la l'agriculture conventionnelle
qui va plus travailler sur l'engraé
l'engrais chimique qui va nourrir
directement la plante en comparaison
donc avec l'agriculture euh
biologique à la Réunion ils sont plus
d'une centaine de producteurs à être
certifiés en agriculture biologique soit
plus de 600 hectares de culture
naturelle salut Pascal salut alors
comment est
bien les
poire le groupement des agriculteurs
biologiques est une structure qui assure
l'accompagnement technique des
producteurs dans leur démarche de
culture
biologique c'est vraiment accompag
constant selon les besoins des
producteurs c'est-à-dire que c'est vrai
que j'ai des producteurs qui sont déjà
très avancés très bons techniquement
donc qui ont moins besoin de moi qui
vont nous faire appel à nous par exemple
sur des problèmes ponctuels des maladies
qu' connaissent pas et il y a des
agriculteurs qui se lancent et où là on
va vraiment construire toute la démarche
avec eux voilà mais après c'est vraiment
au besoin et généralement c'est une
visite tous les deux semaines à peu près
on est en partenariat avec le
département he qui qui nous soutient
dans notre démarche pour développer et
promouvoir l'agriculture biologique donc
moi mon mon poste est pris en charge en
partie par par le département et en
autre partie par l'Europe et au niveau
des agriculteurs je fais aussi le lien
d'informer les agriculteurs de toutes
les aides qui sont proposés par le
département et qui malheureusement ne
sont pas forcément bien connus lors de
son installation et de sa reconversion
en agriculture biologique Pascal dijou a
bénéficié de l'accompagnement du
département de La
Réunion la collectivité met à
disposition des agriculteurs un ensemble
de mesures des aides à l'investissement
à la formation et à la modernisation des
exploitations nous avons avec l'Europe
avec les fonds fader validé maintenant
l'ensemble des dispositifs financiers
concernant l'investissement pour le
monde agricole je parle en terme de
mécanisation en terme de création
d'abris Souss de bâtiment d'élevage tous
ces dispositifs aujourd'hui sont
actionnés et on attend de la part des
agriculteurs qu'ils interpellent les
services instructeurs pour pouvoir
déposer leur dossier et obtenir
l'accompagnement de l'Europe et la
contrepartie nationale qui va venir du
département pour pouvoir les installer
les aider à la modernisation de leur
exploitation et au développement de leur
exploitation nous sommes maintenant
rentrés dans une véritable dynamique
agricole à la Réunion et grâce au
programme européen qui est aujourd'hui
activé nous allons pouvoir accompagner
nos agriculteurs jusqu'en
[Musique]
2020-2022